no idea is above scrutiny and know
people are beneath dignity and what what
I mean by that is that no idea in Islam
like any other religion and any other
philosophy and political thought and
Creed is an idea and ideas by definition
are adopted voluntarily and therefore
should be subject to scrutiny and and so
I don't subscribe to any form of
blasphemy or censorship when it comes to
an intellectual and rigorous debate
around any idea I on the other hand know
people are beneath dignity so no idea is
above scrutiny know people are beneath
dignity and what I mean by that is it's
very easy when understanding it in this
way to recognize and you can recognize
it in your gut the difference between
somebody who's saying I don't like the
religion of Islam let me scrutinize it
you know that's I think this whole thing
about a the literal word of God does and
doesn't sit comfortable with me that's
very different to someone saying all
Muslims are terrorists and they are a
disease in America we must expel them
you know your gut can recognize the
difference between those two I think
Muslims as a people deserve every
dignity like any other human being but
every single idea the Charlie Hebdo is a
case in point people have the right the
absolute right to scrutinize and
satirise and so I think my ideas around
this were crystallized in my
conversation with Sam there's an analogy
I use in the dialogue which I took from
another ex Muslim that we refer to by
name in the book Ali rizvi is a Canadian
ex Muslim who says that it's like saying
smoking is bad and that doesn't imply
smokers are bad people you know to say
smoking is bad doesn't mean I'm saying
all smokers are bad people
so if sam harris is saying he doesn't
agree with islam it doesn't mean he's
saying all muslims are bad people and i
think that's an example that that comes
from this maxim no idea is above
scrutiny you know people are are beneath
dignity and that's one of the things I
took away from from this dialogue and
I'm you know though the phrasing of that
is something which I put in the book the
concept the idea is something I took
from from people like Sam and I'm very
happy that I've that my own thoughts
have developed along these lines when it
comes to that a lot of the motivation
that people have from not wanting to
have this conversation is political
correctness they don't want to be seen
as racist and unfortunately they were
aggressive left today have become
incredibly trigger-happy
at throwing this label at people I've
been called a racist and this
Reverb and many other things a native
informant and a porch monkey sam
Harris's porch monkey for example is a
racist slur simply for having this
conversation you know you'd have thought
that people would recognize that a
Muslim speaking to perhaps one of the
leading atheist Islamic critics to today
that those two having a dialogue with
each other would be a good thing but
instead you know both Sam and I have
been they have faced a barrage of of
criticisms that are ad hominem and there
are not substant substantive and and a
lot of that is motivated by those who
have a concern again for political
correctness who have good intentions but
this is a classic example of where
literally the road to hell is paved with
those good intentions because you cannot
justify calling somebody like me who you
know I fought neo-nazis throughout my
teenage years I've been jailed because
of my previous convictions religious
convictions and you're gonna call me a
racist and an Islamophobe in ER and it's
just you know and even worse a porch
monkey and that's meant to be so on a
liberal side of this debate so people
that on the one hand want to preserve
political correctness I find that they
become incredibly aggressive and and use
and hurl pejoratives at those engaging
in this debate and yet from the other
side of their mouths they're insisting
and that it's not politically correct to
scrutinize Islam no you know I've got a
I've got a view that I think Islamism
must be intellectually terminated and
Islam should be reformed Islam today you
know our view of Islam today needs
reform and and because I distinguish
between Islamism and Islam I can say
that I mean Islamism is a theocracy it's
a desire to impose a version of Islam
over Society theocracy has absolutely no
place are in the modern world it needs
to be intellectually terminated as an
idea and that means through rigorous
debate and and scrutiny but on top of
that Islam itself it's not politically
incorrect to recognize that Islam's
heyday in the Jewish Jewish prudence
that developed around Islam peaked in
the in the medieval era and a lot of it
isn't suitable compatible to the
standards that we've come to adopt today
and the scientific advances but also the
moral standards and values in society
that also requires some
scrutiny by theologians and by thinkers
and you know if political correctness is
going to obstruct that process then it's
going to tolerate a great deal of
bigotry and Prejudice in the process and
so it's not really politically correct
to take that stand at all you know we
know that the neoconservative years led
to the war on terror decade and the war
on terror laws and Guantanamo and
invasion of countries and people the
regressive left especially have a
knee-jerk reaction it's almost a
zero-sum game for them if you criticize
Aslam ISM you must be a neocon Zionist
Indian agent stooge mi6 you know all
these other conspiracies then get tacked
onto the end and a porch monkey right so
it's a zero-sum game for them and how to
defend oneself against this to say look
I'm a liberal i VI opposed the Iraq war
from my jail cell in Egypt I've been a
liberal Democrat parliamentary
candidates in the United Kingdom I ran
for Parliament for office as a Liberal
Democrat you know I'm a bonafide liberal
I've every single war on terror law that
violated human rights principles as I've
understood them
I have opposed them publicly whether
it's the the schedule seven in the UK
that denies the right to silence it
denies it forcibly takes your DNA at
ports of entry and exit airports
what-have-you arbitrary detention
Guantanamo I have always been opposed to
containable and its existence I've been
opposed to the invasion of Iraq no
matter how much I clarify that there are
people for whom as I said this is a
zero-sum game debate if you're critical
if you're critical of his lives it is
amidst extremism you must automatically
be a neocon and a racist and as I said I
mean I've experienced neo-nazi racism
and it's it's absurd to me for anyone to
hold that accusation actually it's
incredibly privileged for them to hold
those accusations at me because I that
they are invariably people who've never
had to dodge a machete attack from a
neo-nazi skinhead or a hammer attack
they've never had to witness torture in
an Egyptian jail yet there are ones
accusing me of being the aslam of a mere
being the racist so how do I deal with
that it's it's an open jury you know to
be honest do I respond every single time
on social media to clarify to send out
links to say no I didn't say that or do
I rise above it and say you guys are
just you know you're petty
I'm not gonna lower myself to your level
because if you wrestle in the mud
with with the pigs you end up getting
dirty so what do you do I don't think
there's an answer to that question and I
don't know I don't know how to go about
it I think one of the things I do do is
I always leave the door open
if if somebody comes back to me and says
look like misunderstood you and I'm
sorry I'm happy to forget and let
bygones be bygones I'm not gonna hold a
grudge I understand how
misunderstandings could could happen
because of course for 13 years I was on
the leadership of an Islamist
organization but I changed my mind
I'm always happy to allow people to
change their minds but how to get them
to that stage and see you as a human
being that has a holistic story behind
them and isn't just one thing or another
you know I don't know I'll keep trying I
suppose